our choices are Hillary and Trump
whether you like it or not
hey I'm Alexis Garcia with reason TV
here at the Democratic National
Convention and you know last week we saw
the never Trump errs this week we see
Bernie or bust fans there's a lot of
dissatisfaction right now with both
candidates and with Gary Johnson getting
closer in the polls to making the debate
stage we asked the Democrats here if
they would be open to hearing more from
a third party option you look at the
polls both candidates have high
unfavorable numbers and one of the
stories we've seen emerge in this
convention is kind of the rise of the
third parties do you think people like
Gary Johnson and Jill Stein should have
a spot in the debates I do not I think I
think which should be closed to who's
been running you know who's been in
there from the front I wouldn't have a
problem with that I think it was I think
it's great to for people to have
multiple choices I think it's perfectly
fine for you know Hillary and for Gary
Johnson and for Donald Trump to put
their ideas out there and let people
decide so I'm not a problem at all I
will say that a well-told story is told
from many perspectives we have to have
all those voices in the room and through
those conversations and at times
conflicts we become stronger any
candidate that you know meets that
threshold should be we do see in
Napoleon Johnson's getting very close to
meeting that threshold to get on the
debate stage would you be open to having
him in the debate of course everybody
has a place in politics so I think that
there you know everybody if he meets the
criteria I think he should I think he
should
it would definitely bring down Hillary's
ratings and it would make it easier for
Trump to keep on bashing because with
another person on stage he can just keep
on throwing things out at people and
with Gary Johnson and Hillary he has
doubled the double the ammo but with one
person to be able to get points across
we could actually have legit debates
about problems that are facing our
society